you can do something fast and crappy for
lack of a better term or you can do it
slow and gold plated and as an executive
the tech executive you have to decide
somewhere in that Spectrum how you're
gonna you know bring the product out the
problem with doing fast and crappy is
that fast and crappy is going to come
and bite you in the backside at some
point in time the question is is when
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20-minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures Jay Ventures
Riverside of Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
today I'm with Gordon allott the
president and CEO of broad Peak Partners
the developer of the K3 K3 is a software
that takes data from anywhere allows
users to transform filter and unify
through an intuitive UI and send it to
anywhere before founding broad Peak
Gordon was a consultant and Maternity in
the financial sector this included
advising a wide variety of bold bracket
Banks and hedge funds on derivative
trading and he led the energy trading
and risk group for Sapient delivering
trading projects for Duke constellation
JP Morgan Chevron and others prior to
Sapient he was part of a startup leading
the USA and VP of Business Development
and VP then Asia pack now Alstrom Gordon
practiced as a derivatives attorney has
a JD from the University of Denver and a
Bachelors of Arts from Drake University
this is going to be a great and fruitful
conversation I'm really
um really curious to hear about your own
Journey as well as that of K3 and and
sort of a human computer interaction
especially with non-technical people
when it comes to data decision making
and organizations so a lot for us to
unpack in these 20 minutes as usual and
um and we'll get started right away tell
me a little bit about your own your sort
of your own connecting the dots looking
backwards if you have to sort of look at
your career go ahead
I mean so uh kind of what I would say is
a very non-traditional technology path
right I was a derivatives attorney in uh
big bank and so we had uh always uh the
so the three founders of the company we
had always worked in in large financial
institutions and
um you know we we got together and and
you know sort of a highlighted a major
problem in the organization around
integration which is it's like every
time you want to try and move data from
one point to another you have to go get
a developer to do it and it creates this
massive bottleneck in the organizations
like the normal way like it's just
you're an executive and you're like look
I need system a to talk to system b or I
need system a b and c to go over to this
database
um the first thing you do is you grab a
developer by the caller and you're like
okay go code it up
and that works actually it works really
well the problem is is that the business
starts changing and uh when the business
changes there go back to that developer
like hey can you come and like redo this
code that you did before and they're
like yeah I'd love to in a month when
I'm done with my current project right
so that's kind of how it all started and
uh you know so K3 we we kind of decided
to to build it differently
um that was the the evolution of low
code integration or that was the the
beginning of it and
we uh we started it differently we we um
we bootstrapped it from the beginning
uh for the first year none of us took
any salaries uh for the first year and
just you know got the product built
um started taking it out to uh the
market and you know we got into Tech
Crunch and some of those kind of things
but you know we we did we we have uh
continued to to bootstrap it so we've
you know we've now uh bootstrapped K3
well through the formative phases into
you know you start going past five six
seven million in Revenue
um and
um yeah I mean you just uh so once you
bootstrap through uh the the sort of the
beginning phases it you just you're just
operating a normal uh a normal software
company
um and so yeah so we've we've continued
to be able to do that without uh any
Venture backing which is a little bit
it's a little bit different Journey
a little bit of a different Journey I'm
sure and
um the decision you know 15 years ago 16
years ago to bootstrap this yeah you
know quite a you know heavy space I I
don't know how many were working on ETL
15 years ago I know that I've I've been
dealing with it myself as an engineer of
course over the last five years or so
what what happened that led to your
entrepreneurial decision to to bootstrap
this and maintain this bootstrapping
environment throughout the journey I
think it was uh you know
in terms of whether to bootstrap or not
bootstrap there I don't think there's
anybody who's anguished over that more
than I have
um because even even today you know we
consider it and the thing you have to
know about bootstrapping is you are
deliberately giving up growth you're
deliberately giving up growth in order
to achieve uh you know basically control
and Destiny the the number one thing
that has kind of kept us in bootstrap
mode is
um
uh kind of our decision making about
product so it's very easy to get out
over your skis as they say in terms of
uh you can sell a product that's not
complete in fact that this is a lack of
a better term sell a product that that
is it is not really ready for prime time
and then you kind of backfill it that's
a very uh that's a very typical thing to
do and and with us I mean I I think that
we we are very deliberate about our
functionality and and how we approach
things we're conscious we're constantly
conscious of what we call technical debt
so you know the the thing is you can do
something fast and crappy for lack of a
better term or you can do it slow and
gold-plated and as an executive the tech
executive you have to decide somewhere
in that Spectrum how you're gonna you
know bring the product out the problem
with doing fast and crappy is that
fast and crappy is going to come and
bite you in the backside uh at some
point in time the question is is when
um and uh you know so so we're
constantly you know thinking about all
of that stuff from a product perspective
um but the other part I think uh the the
three founders is we just didn't want
the noise
um we we were you know a lot of some
investors are very awesome and sort of
give good Sage advice and others are
very loud and pushy and and really want
to you know drive you into you know
higher and higher echelons of Revenue so
which is fine
um but you know it is uh you know just
in terms of of uh ourselves yeah that's
that's uh that that's been our approach
to it
and so as you uh have seen the market
from back 15 years ago to today how has
the market shifted how has the landscape
changed in your perspective and in your
understanding of the needs of these
customers
well the needs are so the needs are
interesting I mean we're squarely a B2B
uh you know Enterprise sale
um so the integration software it's for
companies who have big data needs move
data in real time all of those kinds of
things
and the the drive for that segment of
business uh is efficiency so and and I
you know this started years ago and it
keeps going which is everyone has to do
more with less I mean
the truth is is like you have the 2008
recession
and there was a lot of jobs lost and
they really didn't come back into the
organization right I mean it that
recession drove efficiencies that quite
honestly just stayed and then we kind of
went into the pandemic and that drove
another wave of efficiencies where you
know look people are doing they're
they're being asked to do a lot more in
their jobs and if you look at it like
just everyone is stretched so
unbelievably thin
um and that creates real opportunity for
technology companies because it's like
look if you can help somebody in their
day-to-day job do things better more
efficiently efficiently so they can go
home and I don't know take their kids to
soccer and stuff like that that is that
is it is uh an amazingly powerful
um
uh sale actually where you're really
just helping people on a day-to-day
basis
and uh that is that is probably
increased I I kind of just see that
increasing more and more I mean if we go
into a recession now I mean there's a
lot of people talking about we're going
to go into a recession globally and that
type of thing
and this is the Catalyst for those
driving those kinds of efficiencies it's
sort of like okay all of a sudden
there's a lot of people who are on the
job market and they know about a real
material problems that they can solve
with the technological solution and
maybe they just couldn't get any air
time for it when they were at their
company and so they start a company and
the next thing you know we've got
something you know pretty pretty awesome
so
um yeah that's uh that that's probably
been the biggest shift I think in the
last you know 10 years or so
so walk me through if you will the sort
of the the product or the journey that
you go through with with an organization
that you work with yeah
the you know it's very interesting
because our our biggest competitor so as
a low code integration ETL solution
our number one competitor is the
internal developer like they they are
some they're like no no I want to build
it you know like okay I get it you want
to build it that's that's okay
um and so the thing is is that we're
really not trying to compete with that
internal developer we're trying to shift
workload which is basically listen we're
going to let's say you've got you've got
three apis and you've got three Legacy
systems and I want to get data out of
those six systems and I want to get it
to a database right at pick one
snowflake Microsoft SQL Server it
doesn't really matter what it is
so in order to move that stuff through
you're going to have to a move it B
stream it uh C transform it
um load it and also has uh basically
some statefulness around it so like did
the data load correctly did it not load
correctly some of those
um you know so features in there so the
way that we've solved that with K3 is by
abstracting most of that into a user
interface so that a business analyst can
tackle 95 of the workflows and
um so you know in terms of data
transformation like we have a rules and
a data rules engine it's just when then
else statements that the business
analysts can deploy to okay it's this
special case and I need to deploy it to
this data right
um so so it doesn't really get rid of
the developer it never it never does
trust me
um it's really just I mean
so it's you know it's the old it's the
old uh adage is kind of like you know
uh a very simple ETL function is like
mapping right so I'm gonna map uh a data
from one system to another
um did you get a comp side master's
degree to Matt data
if it's kind of can you do it yes you
can do it you can do it in Python you
can do it very quickly but if you do it
in pi and it's your Python and you do it
you own that forever right I mean you
are never gonna be able to let go of
that and the whole idea is like what we
have to stop this stuff and this low
level stuff
developers don't waste your time on it
it really kind of um
when developers start you know talking
about their you know their ETL prowess
on python it's kind of like okay that's
that's probably very true but you're
shooting yourself in the foot brother I
mean it's kind of like because in a big
company you're never going to be able to
that code is always going to have your
name on it and you're never going to be
able to let go so this is where we come
in it's like look we're gonna we're
gonna put this into a recreatable
environment where business analysts can
get in and do 95 of all of those
functions and that's it and you know it
it's it's just a kind of a better way to
go but that's the that's the type of
efficiency that we're trying to to push
in the organization
so if you had to if you had to
um think to sort of Envision what or
distill what is the vision of K3 you
know long term how do you define the
vision of the company yeah so so for us
it is all about so it is it is driving
Data Solutions right so so companies
have data problems and we are here to
solve those problems sometimes they're
very hard problems and sometimes they're
not hard at all but at the end of the
day here's what here's what you normally
see is
um you know it's sort of like hey you're
a CEO of a company can you see
could you see today your daily p l like
can you see your like a p l explained
where I can see how much money we made
today I can see how much we spent today
and you can see the bottom line today
and see all of those levers that are
happening now that's a that's a
brilliant data idea
and the whole idea is can we get the
data to populate that real-time p l for
example uh or some other business metric
and and the trick is is that in large
Enterprise
you run into a lot of politics you
allowed to run into a lot of stuff and
the whole idea is like let's democratize
that data and come up with real and
meaningful Data Solutions so that we can
achieve these goals and that is our that
is our absolute Mission as a company is
solving data problems that's that's what
we are all about
awesome I love that and tell me a little
bit about your own your own Journey so
both you know even take me back 15 years
to the Inception of K3 from from
personal standpoint what what happened
there for you
we were so it's kind of uh you know so
so I started out as a lawyer
um and it wasn't very long before I
realized that I really wasn't into
practicing law
um and I got you know really pulled into
the technology side so started doing
business development for a software
company back in Silicon Valley
um and that really uh hoovered me into
the technology world and and you know
I've kind of been hooked on it ever
since so
um and you know it's one of those things
where I I absolutely love technology I
am a total technophile in terms of
and I gotta tell you it this is the
Golden Age of Technology you cannot keep
up with all of the amazing just even
just keeping up with you know what's
rolling out on Apache and stuff like
that is is a full-time job let alone
some of this other stuff I mean there is
just there's Tech new technologies that
are rolling out all the time that again
can make really profound changes so I
have always loved that stuff and and you
know really uh Amazed by some of that
stuff about how we can you know uh how
could we pull this together into a
product and so
um we were all we were all doing I
actually got got pulled in and uh was uh
doing a after Lehman Brothers I was I
was brought in to help wind down that uh
that portfolio in bankruptcy actually as
a consultant and uh you know we we sort
of the three of us three founders we
just got together we're like we let's
let's start a software company let's
let's just do this and so we just we
just jumped in
uh we got a tiny little office and it
had at the time we weren't even using
AWS and we had a big server that was so
loud you couldn't hear anybody but it
couldn't hardly hear anything in the
office
um and uh yeah we started building K3
and just uh just started hacking away at
it until we came up with a viable
product that
of course I was uh in charge of doing
all of the sales and business
development and marketing back in those
days and so yeah it was it was a really
it's been a US incredibly fun journey
and the the trick is is I will I do say
this to new entrepreneurs which is you
know the thing is is
the first year I don't care what kind of
company you are I don't care whether
you've gotten funding or not funding the
first year is a quarter mile crawl
through broken glass right I mean it is
just it is a the first year is the
hardest slog and you just have to keep
crawling keep crawling it sucks nobody's
you know you're making calls nobody's
calling you back don't worry about it
keep crawling and you know because what
happens is you get through that first
year your brand starts getting some uh
people start you know recognizing you
they're like oh okay my I know that guy
he's yeah okay that guy he's he's he's
he's he's a good guy he's these are good
guys I I understand what they're doing I
know what they're trying to do you just
have to make it through that first year
it's tough
yeah I love that did you anticipate the
journey as it was well or what was the
most surprising part of the
entrepreneurial Journey that you've
experienced
um the the well the the surprising part
is was was for me is like you're doing
that crawl and then it turns and when it
turns so you kind of have the the
product Market set together the product
is doing what you need it to do the
sales message has kind of made its you
you've got it polished up correctly
where your target the messages is
resonating with the customer
and you know that happens when they
start to when you're in a meeting with
them and they can start visualizing what
they can do with it
that's the turn and when the turn
happens it's absolute magic it's really
fantastic and it I got to tell you it
just takes a while to get there it
doesn't happen overnight
um and you really do kind of have to get
in and you know wrestle with the ideas
around you know what your product is and
and what it needs to do and all of those
kind of things that's the surprising
thing and it's amazing when it happens
I can see in in the sentence and in your
eyes that you're reflecting back to
those moments when the when it actually
happened and and it sounds like it was a
very very meaningful
and validation and transition from the
crawl to yeah walking and I I remember
listening to Steve Jobs and he was
talking about when the iPhone first came
out and you know they were sort of like
uh might might be a thing it might not
be a thing and then he went out and he
started seeing people with the white you
know the original white headphones and
he's like it's happening
it's kind of like that right it's like
it's happening yeah yeah awesome Gordon
I really want to thank you for the time
um
looking forward to continue trying from
the side best of luck with K3 and the
remaining journey and the many more
Journeys to come thank you very very
much thank you so much I appreciate it
thank you
[Music]